c'est l'un des bâtiments les plus
photographiés du centre-ville la porte
Sauvigny ouvre actuellement ses portes à
un public très intéressé et pour cause
l'édifice datant du 15e siècle est en
vente son histoire reste son atout
premier
on est ici dans la pièce juste au-dessus
de la rue la rue d'entrée la rue Buffon
qui rentre dans ce mur et nous avions
donc le pont-levis qui ouvrait de ce
côté-là côté rue et nous sommes dans la
chambre de manœuvre du pont-levis ce
bâtiment emblématique inhabité depuis
200 ans offre une vue imprenable sur les
toits Bourguignons un argument pour
aider les futurs acquéreurs à se
projeter
j'y verrai tout simplement un gîte de
luxe par exemple avec ces petits
garde-robe avec des dispositifs
évidemment de sanitaires à installer
dans une des pièces mais l'ensemble est
totalement unique des pièces comme ça on
les fabrique pas aujourd'hui c'est dans
une situation pareille en ville c'est
totalement impossible l'immeuble de 150
mètres carrés se compose d'un
rez-de-chaussée de trois étages et de
combles un pan du patrimoine dans la
cité médiévale de ce mur en eau soie
ce plan de 1721 on voit bien justement
ce pour Notre-Dame et comment il était
protégé par un système de muraille on
retrouve d'ailleurs les portes la porte
Sauvigny qui est juste ici donc on a
vraiment l'impression de passer d'un
monde à un autre voilà de passer les
portes du temps quand on franchissait
ses portes un bâtiment classé au
monument historiques avec ses
contraintes et ses avantages vendus 230
000 euros pour 600 000 euros de travaux
le bien est présenté comme une
opportunité d'investissement
nous sommes sur un système où vous avez
un système de subvention qui peut être
pour le gros œuvre jusqu'à 50% du
montant des travaux quand même pour tout
ce qui est entretien gros travaux gros
œuvre et aménagement et le reste à
charge surtout et des fiscalisables du
revenu imposable en totalité et ça c'est
pas négligeable non plus ce qui fait que
c'est quasiment une opération blanche à
condition d'avoir les moyens pour payer
l'avancée un peu les travaux et payer le
sol une dizaine de visiteurs ont déjà
manifesté leur intérêt vendu en l'état
sans pont-levis la porte sauvie n'y
attend désormais le coup de cœur de son
futur acquéreur